Tristan hey tiger belly there's a girl I
work with that I've liked for some quite
some time whoever I know she doesn't
feel the same way I really want to get
over her but haven't been able to stop
my feelings for her what advice last
tips could you give me to get over a
crush he's a girl or guy this is that
guy I don't know okay I name is Tristan
Tristan a guy getting over a crush oh my
god those are the worst kind just I
don't know I mean it's like when I had
had many crushes like that
when I was younger oh you tell us about
the diary not only that like when I used
to like there was a girl I worked with
us as waiting tables nice to walk by her
when I smelled her hair but you went up
and like she wasn't like oh well I was a
busboy and there was this girl Anna that
I had a crush on and I would try to make
it the same shifts at her and then while
she was at a table I would walk by her
with like a busing tray and smell her
hair
and then I would end up going to coffee
shops which I saw her there once and
wait there all day just so that I could
run into her yeah and there's that's a
debt because when I did finally a year
later I finally said something she was
already seeing somebody else and she
didn't feel the same way it's a dead
thing
Kristen it's over just either go ahead
get rejected move on
yeah Gary get a solid rejected is he's a
solid rejection I mean a bunch of people
have got it so did you move on that's
the case like but I think you're
addicted to those that pain that's why
you get rejected like anyway all the
times right yeah yeah yeah and I think
that you're addicted to that kind of
love unrequited love and you keep
yourself putting it yourself in those
situations I really believe that with
you that you like that feeling of being
rejected and you like being sad and it
motivates you to try harder with your
business or whatnot but that's how you
use where you get your motivation
interesting George do you know that
about you neither did I but I believe
that I really do it's not a joke I don't
think people a lot of people have fun
getting rejected sweetie no people no I
got I shake I was addicted to it right
don't I loved I loved getting hard
crushes on people
right and then have been getting
rejected and then just like getting
depressed over for four or five months I
got addicted to that being the victim in
that way and listen to sad music and
smoking cigarettes and feeling sorry for
myself I was addicted to that oh the emo
fee yeah and then what motivated me to
do stand-up in when I was 23 was those
feelings of rejection I you gave me
motivation so I look at George in the
same way no I can't get any work done
when I'm sad
that's what like I have to be working
hard like I have to like to be happy I
have to be accomplishing things so if
I'm too sad to accomplish something I
hate it and I can vouch for this because
when stuff was going through a few weeks
ago and stuff was going on with George
and he got rejected and we were supposed
to do a vlog together he said look I'm
just not feeling my best and I can't do
any work today and I was like whoa
George said he can't work him and that
was such a new thing for me because
you're always so reliable so I believe
that I'm sorry George but no my fail
quickly well I you have to notify like
you have to get the failure so that you
know you you can move on but also that's
so great though because if you start
getting used to the possibility of
rejection it does make you bolder it's
like look yeah there is a 50/50 chance
it could she could say yes she could say
no but just play the [ __ ] game at
least say it out loud there's nothing
worse than sitting on a maybe possibly
or swing I should have had just [ __ ]
swing yeah those situations you played
wrong which one's all of them you know
he's not a closer as it was said many
times host podcasts where George they
hear yeah I mean you're just not a
closer
and that's what you need to work on is
to close the deal fast and be a predator
you know you you up front you get the
rejection if they don't want it you move
on that's exactly what George said yeah
but that somebody does ah he did move on
no he didn't he's holding a picture of
Jessica right now audio people can't see
him anyway get rejected fast that's it
is that the older those are the emails
[Music]